[Musique]
on l'attend
c'est le fleuve nourricier de l'asie le
mékong près de 70 millions de personnes
en dépendent pour la pêche ou les
rizières mais ce fleuve mythique subite
aujourd'hui les assauts répétés de
l'homme
au cambodge des dragueurs pompe chaque
jour des millions et des millions de
tonnes de sable du mékong une soif qui
peu à peu détruit les écosystèmes
à force de pomper dans le lit de la
rivière les berges se sont même affaissé
à certains endroits c'est d'habitants
vit sur l'une de ses rives aujourd'hui
en reconstruction
c'est l'un des rares riverains qui
accepte de s'exprimer mais il le fait de
manière anonyme
je ne suis pas heureux quand je vois ce
qui est pompée parce que ça détruit les
ressources naturelles
le terrain que j'avais aller là-bas
jusqu'au bateau
une dizaine de militants écologistes qui
ont osé questionner publiquement ces
pratiques ont été envoyés en prison au
cambodge car les enjeux financiers sont
énormes
le sable du mékong tard est en fait
d'alimenter des chantiers gigantesques à
plusieurs milliards d'euros
direction phnom penh
la capitale cambodgienne en plein boom
immobilier
c'est ici qu'arrivent le sable utilisés
pour construire sur le mékong ces
immenses terrains artificiels
le remblaiement a aujourd'hui manger une
grande partie du fleuve
à la place sera édifié cette ville
satellite
avec quel impact sur le mékong
officiellement des études ont été
réalisées mais elles n'ont jamais été
rendues publiques
sollicité le gouvernement et les
promoteurs immobiliers n'ont pas donné
suite à nos demandes
les chantiers menace aujourd'hui
plusieurs communautés de phnom penh vie
nos abeilles ne s'allume que ces gens
devront en fin de compte déménager et
ils ne veulent pas parce qu'ils vivent
ici depuis des décennies
alors à la mairie vous on dit quoi ce
directeur d'une ong est l'un des rares
sur lequel ses habitants peuvent compter
pour essayer de sauver leurs maisons
nous habitons ici dans des espaces
naturels on attraper des poissons pour
les vendre et on cultivait des légumes
maintenant on a perdu ce mode de vie
parce que les grosses compagnies ont
rempli les lacs
une communauté qui risque d'être rayé de
la carte
car les lacs de phnom penh alimentée par
le mékong ont également été comblé par
le sable du fleuve pour créer elle a
aussi d'immenses terrains destinés à la
promotion immobilière
est un outil qui marche sur un ancien
lac ne s'oppose pas par principe au
développement
mais selon lui les autorités sacrifie
l'écosystème du mékong au bénéfice de
certains privilégiés mais une grande
question pour le gouvernement pour qui
sont ces projets d'habitation parce
qu'une grande partie des pauvres ne peut
pas se le permettre
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été expulsés
forci quitter la ville
est ce vraiment pour les gens ordinaires
ouest pour les riches et les
investisseurs
à ces nouveaux aménagements sur le
mékong s'ajoute une autre problématique
centrale pour l'avenir du fleuve celle d
immense barrage hydroélectrique
construit en amont au laos ou ici en
chine
d ouvrage gigantesque qui modifie
l'équilibré du mékong pour des millions
de pêcheurs en aval
comme au cambodge
quarante ans que cet homme pêcher dans
les eaux autrefois généreuse du mékong
mais lui et tous les autres pêcheurs ont
tout simplement abandonné le poisson
pour se reconvertir dans la collecte de
coquillages
avec l'accumulation des barrages le
poisson en le fleuve est devenu de plus
en plus rares